it's 4:00 in the morning
when the fisherman of Salone a head out
to sea to cast their nets and settle
down for the long haul francisco for two
only knows if his patience is paid off
after sunrise he used to catch up to 100
kilos a day but in the past few years
his catch has dwindled dramatically
after three hours the fisherman returned
to their village and sell their catch at
the local market today there are slim
pickings not even enough to make a
living it only covers the cost of
keeping the boat paying for its fuel
it's nowhere near enough as a daily wage
once they're done with fishing for the
day the people of Silla neighs start on
the day's chores
Vinicio Vergara is the head of the
community which number is more than a
thousand people almost all of them live
from fishing
that'll travel eight we all struggle
when we see what small numbers the
fishermen have caught what they bring in
each day affects the whole community and
it leaves its mark because they all work
so hard and do their best to support
their families sir learn a is situated
on the Verdi Island passage a 100
kilometer long straight in the northern
Philippines it's believed to be home to
more documented species than any other
marine habitat on earth and with more
than 300 species of corals it's also
considered one of the largest
concentrations of corals in the country
if not the whole world but in recent
years climate change has resulted in
rising temperatures and sea levels as
well as extreme weather the population
of the Veda island passage is also
dealing with the consequences of
man-made problems such as overfishing
and a weakened Rheneas works for
Conservation International an
environmental organization that
researches the effects of climate change
in the region
it also helps communities like Sydney to
cope with the repercussions we try to
determine which among the provinces and
even the municipalities and even the
communities who are vulnerable to
climate change so as a result of that
study we determined that there are some
areas here in the Verde Island Passage
that are that are vulnerable and Sedona
is one of the most vulnerable to storm
surge flooding erosion coastal erosion
and of course storm surges insulin a
climate change is happening before
locals very eyes sandbags and other
measures can do little to hold back the
tide eight years ago there were houses
here now there's just water
locals are determined to protect their
homes they've planted thousands of
mangrove
which serve as a barricade against storm
surges the mangrove conservation area is
also providing them with an income they
started renting kayaks to visiting
tourists they're well aware that they
can no longer rely on fishing for their
livelihoods so they're looking for
alternatives local women have banded
together and started producing crackers
all they need is pumpkins salt and flour
they come together four times a week to
make these low-cost snacks and then sell
them to schools for example their next
goal Selena is making preparations to
become an eco village everyone is taking
part all Mabul is among those fighting
the threat of climate change with small
but decisive steps it's very important
for every member of the community to
work together to achieve our goal
because if we don't everything that
we've started would be useless and if we
don't help ourselves there's no chance
for other people to help us either so we
really need to work hand-in-hand as a
team the capital of the Philippines
Manila is on the neighboring Island the
understanding that climate change will
affect the entire country has sunk in
the government has established a climate
change commission tasked with
coordinating monitoring and evaluating
the programs and action plans of the
government relating to climate change
governor Alfonzo Imani is a member of
the Commission a lot of Ana a lot of
interventions that this climate change
commission did so it was a planning it
was a consultative planning actually we
did have all the stakeholders together
and they discussed what what to do
to offend the coastal town of Colette
agon is about an hour's drive from
Manila it's a commercial fishing hobby
fishermen are waiting to see what sort
of catch the day is brought
studies show that fish stocks are likely
to dwindle here too
for this reason fishing has been cut
back during the spawning season after
lengthy debate authorities and fishermen
have reached an agreement on seasonal
closures we're a well-organized group of
fishermen in kala tagging we were
already informed and told about the
impact of overfishing so we have a plan
and we're waiting to implement it but
like the people of Salone the fisherman
and Colette again will have to start
thinking up alternative sources of
income collar tagging probably won't
stay this busy but at least the fishing
industry won't die out completely